[Music]
[Applause]
let's start with how beautiful your home
is it's just so nice I love this place
thank you yeah I'm new money well you
know how to spend it you out there are
we allowed to talk about the fact that
this is your house yeah yes I don't have
people that want to kill me
Whitney's no I'm just there it's too far
away
Chicago yeah Chicago middle of metaphor
yeah you'll give up on me uh someone who
was threatening my life recently said if
I if I don't respond to you I'm gonna
move on to Evangeline Lilly Wow and I
was like it's quite a threat I think I
need a response oh he doesn't move on to
her situation I was like as an act of
charity towards her now the Bloods out
my hair you probably freaked him out he
probably was like this girl is weird I
only go to people who fear me yeah and
then um
it is interesting because I the first
first stalker I ever had the glory days
when they would just call you and didn't
have reverse Google search or whatever
to find your homes and he would just
call me all day and basically all these
detectives came over and they were like
you just need to talk to him on the
phone so that he'll move on to someone
else like it's it's usually about the
chase for them so you just basically
what they were implying was like if he
talks to you right he'll never call that
we we've listened to your stand-up like
you just your personality will repel him
it will break the spell I think you're
selling yourself short I had two minutes
to talk to him he called with all the
detectives around we talked for a couple
minutes
he wasn't not charming oh my goodness
but which stage of your life was this
had you been single for my twenties I
have a very cloudy where they sat there
you were coming I was like so you have a
wife cuz then I'd really be I was twenty
five the more unavailable the best
twenty five I was probably twenty five
yeah I was Romeo 25 and this was kind of
before the internet and stuff I think
before they could access lots of people
before Instagram you know I was like
MySpace or something um it was you know
and so uh then he got nervous got hung
up the phone and they told me just be
very clear don't deny his reality okay
and never call me again really is it
because you were a little forward oh I'm
a bit worried about the fact that cuz I
thought the idea would be that you just
get on and be like boring anyway that's
what I would call it back and be like
hey I'm normally not this boring they
told me to just be like I could have
kept I they told me to just be kind of
quiet like I'm funny charming but the
detectives so just FYI my goodness I
hope you've got better than this because
between that and then the Evangeline
Lilly thing I don't think you're
handling this I think this is an
intervention
do you say something out loud and you
don't realize how insane it sounds cuz
I'm normally around comedians but you're
a well-adjusted healthy person and I'm
realizing I have some work to do I'm a
person recognized mental illness when
you see I'm using comedians who are like
he didn't call you back did you find him
on insurance just send them a naked
photo you can get it back oh wild so I
don't know how to ask this but I'm just
gonna ask it okay
because I think it's time it's been time
for white people to be comfortable and
afraid to make mistakes
and to make them and to don't ask
in my opinion your friends of color what
you should do there's enough resources
out there at this point I'll get to that
at the end the podcast but I did just
want to ask you how you're feeling
gosh it's a it's a it's a great question
and I'm gonna frame it like this
recently we had the me to movement and
you know I spoke to a lot of women who
it was both liberating for and painful
for because it was something that they'd
been living with for most of their lives
and now they felt that they weren't
crazy they suddenly felt like they had a
sisterhood they felt that they had other
people with whom which they could share
their experiences and you know one of
the things I would talk about with these
with these friends as we had more and
more men who were you know going down in
flames quite rightly so for their
behavior and I would talk about if there
is room for redemption for some of these
guys on the basis of a genuine apology
when you ask me show reboot well there
are limits to everything with me I think
the judicial system decided upon that
very thing but but you know like because
dare I say it there are degrees and and
and then you know you talk to people and
and the first thing that would come at
me which I now understand a little bit
more is why is it now on us to redeem to
forgive we have been the ones who have
been being sexually abused assaulted in
a small way and a big
for years you know all sorts of
variations on that and I now understand
it a little bit more now because what I
have had over the last couple of weeks
especially in the light of the the the
George Floyd murder is I'm very
aggressively about this is don't call
that police brutality that's murder it
is like I just using that police
brutality just kind of sanitizes it a
little bit so I just think we have to
everyone make sure you let's let's call
a spade a spade here and I think you
know even though I understand and I
think it's actually beautiful having
friends say how are you I'm so sorry
what can I do but you know there's that
part of you that can feel like I now
have to do even more work I am exhausted
I mean I have cried so much in the past
week or so
I have I I I've talked to other other
black people who are very engaged in
this space and we are exhausted from the
emotional toll from it taking such a
graphic image to feel heard when you had
a motto Bree only a couple of weeks
beforehand you have Rihanna Taylor who
they were all reported you know Mike
Brown was reported Trayvon Martin was
reported it took an eight-minute video
from three angles and you know what else
it took Whitney it took us being
softened up by having a pandemic that
has made us all entertain struggle mmm
deaf ill health economic uncertainty
being holed up at home mm-hmm no no one
knows when things are gonna get better
so that that set of circumstances is
what black people live with all the time
not knowing when things are going to get
better economic uncertainty
of going outside of going outside a
world that feels unsafe a world that
feels uncertain literally we and I'm not
saying that we live with that in a
conscious way but we live with it in a
way that other people are now also
having to live with it and it was
focusing you know I think that in a
divine sense the thing that for me now
gives this very devastating thing we are
going through with the the pandemic is
I'm hoping that it will give this moment
meaning hmm because those over a hundred
thousand deaths here in America alone
sixty percent of which are black and
brown people and you're going Wow
yet again yeah are we bearing the brunt
of this but if the legacy is that this
country genuinely changes I think they
would not have passed in vain mmm-hmm
but you know in answer to your question
how am i doing I'm doing better this
week than I was last week because also
black people are so used to seeing an
image like that and having to reconcile
with the fact that it's not gonna change
those cops are gonna get off everyone's
gonna pay attention for a moment and
move on but what happened this time 1012
days of protests growing protests
Minneapolis yesterday saying that they
were going to completely rethink their
their police system a bill that dropped
today from Nancy Pelosi which we don't
know what's in the bill but it's a bill
nonetheless around policing so there are
the kind of shifts and changes that make
you go maybe maybe this is a moment
beyond which things will not be the same
and I think what you're saying is
reminding me of something that Wanda
Sykes posted the other day which was
white people have to solve this problem
this is a white person problem
and you don't tell the victims to fix
the abuser right you would never tell a
battered woman to go to her wife and say
can you stop she already said that yeah
and if black people could do this alone
it would be done right we've done
everything I think that's where partly
where the exhaustion comes from we've
marched we've made music we've fought
for the country and for all their lives
us we've had presidents who did eight
years we we've we've we've we've
protested violently we've protested
peacefully we make movies make yeah
we've made we've made movies we've done
I think pretty much everything you can
do without a full-on revolution and I
think what what people may have ears to
hear a new is that baked into the
foundation of the inception of this
country is this evil you know people
were stolen from a continent dumped on
this continent the people who already
lived on this continent were also that
knee on the neck is symbolic yeah it's
what happened to the Native Americans is
what happened to Africans is what
happened to Mexicans America is is
beautiful yes in so many ways and I
think today it's feeling to me in the
last two weeks and of course I'm late
yes of course I'm late I was taught
slavery was over right I was taught it
ended like no one it is so funny because
I actually reached out to my high school
to ask them what history book they were
teaching when I learned about this
because as I've been way too late
educating myself on some of the stuff
now I am learning things about the
ancestral trauma of this because in what
you said before about the pre-existing
conditions
don't have to
they have to do with the fact that black
people are more likely to live in
polluted areas right have post-traumatic
stress anxiety disorder all the time the
toll that takes on your immune system
hypertension black women being four
times more likely to die in childbirth
because 50% of medical professionals
believe that black women have a higher
tolerance for pain so don't treat them
as quickly and these are reverberations
from so long ago and learning that in
1807 slavery I remember learning this
and and literally thinking it was like
good news mmm in 1807 when and I'm
actually gonna stop for a second because
Tana he C code says that he does and I
think words are important really
important and we talk about them a lot
on this podcast and at the risk of
overthinking I just he explained that he
stopped using the word slave because it
implied that that was their identity
right that they were born slaves they
weren't slaves they were enslaved and so
I'm gonna try to course-correct on that
and that in people enslaved people
stopped being imported from Africa in
1807 and I remember going well that's
great news no one taught me that that
actually meant that slave owners
required female slaves to have more
children and that it tore families apart
because they started selling within
America and just taking sums from their
parents etc so I I'm fresh angry
frustrated whatever that I I didn't get
this information it's time to get this
information you know I couldn't agree
with you more and I feel like there are
the ears to hear it you know when we
when we the reason I resist a failed
experiment is because I think it's a
redeemable experiment I genuinely do but
in order for that to be the case what
you're just talking about historic
speaking needs to be understood and
needs to be broken down and because part
of for me the definition of white
privilege is the privilege to not have
to understand it to not have understood
it but also to have been a beneficiary
of that system you benefit without us
acknowledging that the the game was
rigged from from the start I mean you
use the analogy of a battered woman you
know Africa is a continent if you think
about what has been done to that
continent both in terms of the slave
trade and colonialism
it is like raping a woman stealing from
her bludgeoning her brutalizing her time
and time and time again and then saying
come on get up sort yourself out pull
yourself up by your bootstraps
let's go right exactly and that and even
though people are going tend to use the
excuse of that was then this is now
I didn't enslave anyone I didn't but you
are living the legacy of it and America
was built on the foundation of a paradox
the founding fathers who are wheeled out
all the time as these righteous guys who
who built this country the the the
paradox is that they were leaving
another totally totalitarian regime to
start a new country and then they built
it on the very same ethos of subjugating
other other people and so based on race
not religion it was right right and so I
guess that what do they say the abused
abuse you know her people her people
yeah people are people you know it's
it's it's a perpetuation of that cycle
and then a rationalization when actually
what's happening is you looked at this
experiment which is America and you
thought we can build wealth we can build
power we need free labor we're going to
steal that free labor but we have these
Christocentric ideas which fly in the
face of it
we are so addicted to money and power
that we are going to pretend that they
are not fully human I want to circle
back to the privileged thing in a second
but you know that I was thinking about
this yesterday because Donaghy tunne you
see her coats again was talking about
the intimacy of slavery that black
children played with white children
right and slept together and were
friends and then when they came of a
certain age then they went their
separate ways and the white child had to
become the abuser of their friend and
the same way you know black people have
inherited the trauma of slavery white
people I believe have inherited the
ability or chosen or whatever dit to
just be able to compartmentalize and
block out because that he was explaining
is what had to happen for these children
to be able to then enslave their friend
you know
they had to learn to basically to
humanize somebody and minimize and numb
their own sympathy or pathos in order to
do something reprehensible so much of
this is about power and that is another
thing that we haven't been able to talk
about because you talk about power and
then a white person says well I'm poor
but I you know I I don't I'm not a rich
person I don't have power I give you an
example so again me too movement so in
the wake of that Hollywood started
paying a little bit more attention to
the fact that they were disgraceful
numbers when it came to female directors
for instance I literally have sat down
with successful white male directors who
have had the audacity to say to me it's
tough for us right now it's really it's
really - I mean this I mean we're all
for me - but it's tough you can't rape
people anymore it's it's a nightmare
what am I to do on my lunch break
the needle like moved five seven percent
of the bikini extras without seeing them
in a bikini at the audition right and
there is no irony no irony - I was like
oh you see who you're talking to right
now and complaining about the fact that
you feeling marginalized because women
are getting a few more opportunities and
that is the level of wilful and guess
what when they take that opportunity
yeah they then can't be with their
children right will feel guilt the
entire time right
can't take half the jobs they're offered
because it shoots in New Zealand and
they have to care for their kids
never mind the whole rest white man your
back because the rest of this year
moms are home homeschooling their kids
right so I mean this isn't what you know
we should spend too much time on but I I
now it's like women that did make you
know progress in the last couple years
are now Amish and have to stay home and
teach their kids and we'll have to pass
on projects that shoot this year you
know yeah and don't have child care at
the set and have to be there till 10:00
p.m. I really hope we don't lose the
games yeah I mean I don't know when
things are gonna bounce back but you
know you make a very good point there
but you know that the thing is that's
that's male priviledge to to to because
again it's a shift of power what's what
what basically happened I think in the
last two weeks is that with Amy Cooper
as well she was exemplary of the silent
racist the person who doesn't realize
they're racists because they have a
privilege that they wield every day of
their lives and it is just endemic so
Amy Cooper is the kind of person who if
what happened to her in in that Park in
New York didn't happen she'd probably be
marching in protest of joy Floyd right
percent you know a liberal a Democrat
upwardly mobile professional you know in
New York one of the most cosmopolitan
cities in the world and she knew the
effect of saying I have an
african-american man who is whatever I
don't remember watch yeah exactly
you know the most unthreatening got a
you know very menacing pair of
binoculars yes inspector
you know but that was that was
indicative of her wielding power yeah
that was power you know and that's what
that's why I think white people are
having to wake up to the idea of seeding
you've got to share this country which
black people helped build it was kind of
built on their backs that's right and I
just learned was recently ashamed to say
that when slavery ended which it ended
but it didn't end I'm now understanding
the the shadow and the way it haunts us
it is still very much alive and well
that the slave labor force was worth
three million dollars and that was more
than any of the assets in America
combined well I mean that's wild
not only wild but you know the the
ability of America to repackage himself
when it comes of this stuff so you had
slavery and then you have those people
who kept the slaves or the enslaved as
you rightly say in line this the the
slave catchers the whatever when when
slavery was abolished
they became essentially the precursor to
cops so that's the lineage you have
slavery sharecropping the prison
industrial complex so you have the slave
catchers slave herders whatever you want
to call them then they in terms of
sharecropping they were they owned the
farms or they helped keep these guys in
line they were kind of cops and now you
have the prison industrial complex you
have this broken judicial system so
there
say a clean and clear line that Ava
Duvernay is film so brilliantly
illustrates in 13 so if there is a line
between slavery and now that can be
drawn in terms of the subjugation
marginalization and enslavement really
for free labor of black people what do
you think is happening on top of that
line when it comes to white people they
remain the beneficiaries and I think the
word the term white privilege I think
when someone hears something a lot that
you get numb to it or a lot of there's
been a lot of virtue signaling and
there's been a lot of performative
activism me and my white privilige and
and first of all admitting you have it
isn't anti-racist work right you don't
get points for that why people really
want points for like admitting like I
have work to do yet don't do the work we
don't need to just go do it tell us that
you're doing saying you're doing the
work doesn't count as work right and
white privilege is interesting because I
I think it's important to admit this is
embarrassing as it is and shameful as it
is like when I was younger and more
insecure and certainly less aware and
more you know self-absorbed
self-obsessed whatever because that's
what it's evolved in that's what
insecure people do they say I'm a piece
of shit at the center of the universe
and white privilege I think a lot of
people your ego gets involved and what
people hear is you didn't work hard
you're not talented you're not special
that's what the ego hears but that's not
what anyone saying no one's saying you
haven't had a hard life no one is saying
you bad things haven't happen to you no
one's saying you're not talented you're
not special didn't work hard we're
saying is a black person could work just
as hard be just as talented be just as
special and not get a fraction of what
you've gotten we're just saying you had
a thousand-yard head start mm-hmm
and I think it's important to note that
you know Billy Porter on his Instagram
the other day was just saying black
people have to work ten times as hard to
get you know half of what you're getting
and Chris Rock I think I'm gonna
paraphrase it but it really made me
think hard when he said black people
will be equal when they're free to be as
mediocre as white people it's so true
because right now I see and no offense
because these are the movies you make
but it seems like in black cinema now
they all have to win Oscars they have to
be oscar-worthy movies and you're in you
know those movies but we have to get to
a place where black people can just tell
stories and they don't have to win
Oscars and they don't have to be the
best you have to be the best at what you
do
yeah if you're black which is again you
know privilege you know for me as an
actor I am consistently reminded not
necessarily vocally but reminded by what
literally happens to me and those around
me if I have a failure or two hmm the
drop in my currency is tangible but you
can see a white actor of the same male
for years for years and why is that
because the people employing them see
themselves in them and so therefore are
essentially protecting themselves do you
want better right they can suck for
twenty years and then when they do like
a serious movie where they play a
dramatic role yeah they get to be
nominated for an Oscar because we're
comparing it to how horrible they were
yeah when they're mediocre
they're Oscar worthy C is so great I
can't be I know it was twenty I thanks
for hanging in there
guys I'm also meteor exactly as well see
it the Oscars yeah I mean you you look
at all you have to look at is how long
it took for Denzel and Sam Jackson and
Morgan Freeman can you wear is there
Shia LaBeouf moment where is there
Leonardo DiCaprio moment that they were
still talented in their 20s that you
didn't see them emerge til their 30s and
40s that's part of the privilege you
don't even have the privilege you don't
even have the opportunity I should say
to be afforded opportunities when you're
in your prime and I this could be way
off base and just correct me if I know
you guys will correct me in the comments
you'll let me know but I think that
working in the business I work and I
maybe I'll just speak for myself or just
in general the people that are on
Instagram that are following you know
Kevin Hart and that are following a
dress Alba and that are following you
know famous Floyd Mayweather who has
planes and stuff it's almost like
getting a false sense of what's going on
look black we were doing great were they
have planes they Bentley's I just said
Chris Hart Kevin Hart's pool he's fun
and um so I think that it's it's so
important to expose what else is going
on and not what's going on in the 1%
yeah and the fact that and I know there
was an argument about this with The
Cosby Show
back in the day because I remember
watching The Cosby showing but there's
more problems with the Cosby Show we'll
have time to do yeah well yeah
round two I remember being like black
people are lawyers great their doctors
great we're good they live in
brownstones we're done right this is why
you know black writers and filmmakers
are so important because young people
have got to see black protagonists and
watching queen of cot way was quite a
joy Frank and everybody's children
should watch it can I just ask you just
about the importance of black presence
in media television art especially and
what to do about right now I'm just
gonna say this I'm trying to get in
trouble I don't care I do feel like
there's a little moment where and you
didn't gringo it from what I understand
which by the way we're going to talk
about your comedy career in a second all
you're doing you're getting the two
levels
I'm spoiler alert of you burning
yourself just like Eddie Murphy level
like genius and but I do feel like
there's a moment and I'm part of these
conversations I hear these conversations
in what I do there's a lot of this was
written for a white guy let's just cast
a black guy but keep writing him as if
he doesn't have the experience of the
black person but there's no black people
in the room to really weigh in so we've
just cast a black person mm-hm and the
actor would have to like say something
and again solve a problem that he
shouldn't have Soph cuz he already wants
to get a job and you know like is there
how do you feel about that it's layered
yeah it's really layered and let's
unpack it so someone like Idris for
instance who people love you know I was
growing up in the UK and I would
remember seeing a dress in in little bit
parts and he came to America because he
could just couldn't get opportunities
that were commensurate with his talent
he just couldn't and he really struggled
and you know anyone who saw Kevin Hart's
documentary on ducky series on on
Netflix will see what he went through to
get to where he got to
and so yes people see these guys and and
and think oh look successful black
people but the price paid to get there I
cannot begin to tell you now it's a
tough profession Kevin gets up at 4:00
a.m. he works I mean you'd have to what
he's how many movies is that guy doing i
mean it's it's incredible his work ethic
unreal that is partly to do with this
thing that's ingrained in you that you
like I say you can't have too many fails
you can't because you'll be you'll be
written off now so that's just to give
context to the fact that these people
are not just you know they are not
privileged in the same way we are
talking about white privilege but images
matter an immense amount and literally
we are in a moment right now that is
indicative of that fact I'll get to what
you're talking about in terms of
representation on screen but in terms of
the image Emmett Till being killed in
1955 was the precursor to the Montgomery
bus boycott when Rosa Parks decided she
was not gonna take it anymore and that's
what led to the 381 days of protests
that desegregated that part of this
country the film we did Selma
it was Bloody Sunday it was how police
brutality was seen on screen that
allowed dr. King to be able to pull in
all of those white people who helped
make that much successful it was then
that Viola Liuzzo and James Reeb were
killed and it became violent where they
were white yeah both sorry yes both both
white white people and so that was the
thing that was shocking in 1965 and made
the country go something is wrong over
there again the image
George Floyd it was the image we haven't
seen that before we haven't seen the
juxtaposition of a face that nonchalant
and indignant whilst killing someone for
that long who's having the life Abdo of
them nonchalant and as John L said last
week a smirk sunglasses on the head
hands and pockets so that image did
something so images are important and if
I may they work and and I was doing my
research on the we'll get to in a second
defund the police and what that means I
think people think it means no more
police that's not what anyone saying
they're saying take some of those funds
and put them into after-school
mental health services reparations you
know and you know I do whatever the
zombies sound so fucking white privilege
the animal rescue stuff I'm very into
because I learned from a psychologist
that when children see animal abuse they
learn very early on exploit the
voiceless and exploit your power that's
what it is right that's what zoos are
that's what SeaWorld is that's what all
this is you're basically learning Oh
make money off something that doesn't
have a voice right you can use it you
can exploit it you can abuse it you can
force it to breed whatever and that that
is a has of it because kids care about
animals right more than sort of humans
right because they love and then they go
see a I love teddy of teddy bears let's
go see a bear then they see a bear in a
ten by ten cage right and they go oh
yeah you can put these glorious things
that should have free lives in cages
right and so and I can pay five bucks
and this is for my ephemeral enjoyment
this subjugation right and so I got
super fascinated by it and um SeaWorld
is pretty much done because of that
aerial image of the Orca it we had to
see that right and guess what the law
ain't laws can change very quickly right
which is why I don't understand the hold
up on this cuz I think I had in my head
laws take like years you got a draft and
you gotta put him through a thing and
you got a vote like I don't know how
long it takes but working in the animal
rescue world and seeing fur was outlawed
like that right right yeah and the
importation of new whales into SeaWorld
is gone however it took us voting with
our pocketbooks so Shannel wasn't like
we actually just like foxes and we care
about them and like we just love animals
people stop buying fur coats right so
they use that opportunity to go you know
we're gonna stop fur and they got this
publicity and they got all this you know
support and same thing with SeaWorld
they the abusers are never gonna go you
know I should stop abusing right they're
never gonna come to that conclusion on
their own because they're Psychopaths
you cannot expect them to just have like
epiphany that they're gonna stop abusing
and there's no literally within a month
there's you can't import whales to
SeaWorld this can change this is doable
but its power right what you just said
there is people stop buying fur people
stopped riding the bus we were already
in a state of economic crisis and so
people I think it's a combination of
seeing George Floyd and what's going
economically yeah and the fact that
we're all feeling the pinch
and you now hear people black people
saying this is how we feel all the time
and we're dying more than you from this
right so that's where I talked about
power and black people don't have it you
had white people who were tired of being
causes it up at home I walk protested
with guns at their side at spitting and
screaming in the face of law enforcement
with with with no tear gas no beatings
nothing and what happened states started
opening because there is power there and
what has given this movement power is
it's not just to the point earlier it's
not just black people but it's everyone
everyone is out in the streets that's
why they have to listen traditionally
it's just been black people who don't
have power and when you talk about
reparations all we want is to own a
piece of the pie that we helped make
it's as simple as that that's right
that is so wonderfully put and and
that's the privilege we would like and
and I wouldn't I wouldn't say that it is
annoying for white people to acknowledge
it it's a relief for it to be
acknowledged because part of the mental
illness that we suffer with
disproportionately is from being made to
feel like you're crazy
yes the gaslighting yeah you just you
just maybe you you say that these things
are affecting you and that they're
happening and people just you
tell they think that you're exaggerating
or playing the race card or you know and
it's not until they see something like
that that you go and you go yes I have
to have conversations with my three sons
that you just shouldn't have to have
about how to interact with the police it
doesn't make sense that I have to be
saying to my kid
forget your rights come home alive but
get your rights as a human being
regardless of whether you're in the
right or not you'd be compliant
complacent you do everything at anything
that because essentially I'm saying they
are the enemy and I need you to come
home alive that is what you are
confronted with as a reality I don't
want that to be my reality but it just
is time for ads
time for some ads but as always I'm not
gonna read the copy like some of these
other podcasters that you listen to that
are just reading robotic Lee and
lifelessly with no joy in their heart
cuz they don't really use the product
but they're just going then about minima
and a promo code Chris D'Elia my Reba I
don't do that
okay because I use advertisers that I
actually use when they don't pay us to
do the pot magic spoon can't stop eating
it it's delicious
I'm obsessed with it Tim Dylan turned me
on to it of all people I take culinary
advice from him which is shocking Google
I mean you'll know why
magic spoon zero sugar zero sugar I get
migraines zero sugar is perfect no
headaches 12 grams of protein in a
cereal in only three net grams of carbs
in each serving no guilt no shame no
2:00 a.m. random running up and down the
stairs to burn calories
that's my 20s for flavors cocoa fruity
frosted and blueberry I'm gonna rank my
favorites I actually you know what
fruity is my favorite it tastes like
fruit loops but without the guilt in the
shame and the sugar crash I like to mix
the frosted in the blueberry and I you
then use chocolate oat milk with it it's
delicious
it's an indulgence midday snack in
addition to breakfast tastes amazing
probably too good to be true but I don't
think so they can't lie they're not
allowed to legally keto friendly gluten
free soy free low carb now Benton's
gonna weigh in because I want you guys
to know that I'm not completely full of
shit and lying to you
you can trust me ok watch he's going to
tell you about all the can you tell our
audience how much I love magic spoon
cereal how many boxes have I made you
order for me I'm not getting free boxes
from them by the way I'm paying Whitney
mad what's your favorite flavor ice I'm
not going to tell you mine that's my
favorite one why are you obsessed with
me why do you have to copy me I love I
said fruity and then I mixed frosted in
blueberry and sometimes cocoa magic
spoon dot-com / Whitney grab a variety
pack try it today see what all the fuss
is about and be sure to use our promo
code Whitney to get checkout at free
shipping this is how we pay Benton magic
spoon is so confident in their product
it's backed with a hundred percent
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money no questions asked that is earned
confidence
that's magic spoon com / Whitney use the
code Whitney for free shipping when we
thank magic spoon for sponsoring the
podcast we talked a lot about mental
health
this podcast we talk a lot about therapy
but what we don't always talk about is
the fact that therapy is freaking
expensive and a lot of people don't have
time to go to it frankly I don't
actually like going to therapy in person
because by the time I get there I'm
already mad at the therapist and I'm so
pissed about parking that my therapist
thinks I have anger management issues
which I don't but I am so pissed off
that I can't and then that I can't not
look angry and then she thinks I have
anxiety and I'm like no this is just
because I only have 40 more minutes on
the meter and we need to run through
this quick I need to do this from home
who made that happen Benton not a crisis
line not self-help professional
counseling done securely online that's
important a lot of therapists can sell
your insurance information to your
insurance company I'm just saying or
your helps mental health you know what I
mean it's just be careful services
available worldwide long into your
account any time send a message to your
counselor you get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions this is key you
do it in the privacy of your own home
you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room like and read
yoga monthly you have to sit there and
play with that little nasty sand
sculpture the way you rake the sand just
a bunch of germs nasty in traditional
offline counseling financial aid is
available god I love the internet better
help wants you to start living a happier
life today there's a lot going on out
there there's a lot of stress on our
brains and on our hearts and on our
mental health and you got a take care of
your mental wealth visit their website
read the testimonials they're posted
daily if you don't trust me which is
ridiculous I play something for you yes
and feel free to tell me to stop playing
anything this makes me emotional this is
a friend of mine posted this and it is a
black teenager saying all the things
his parents so what does what privileged
look like not having to have that
conversation with your child ever that
that's a privilege that I I'm not
afforded and so the point you made
earlier about the images we put out I
cannot play the black best friend I will
not play a criminal I cannot play a
slave why not because I can't or I'm not
offered those because I am determined to
be the answer to the question I have to
ask myself every day I get out of bed
every day are you what they say you are
well if you're not you better go out
there and live live it so that so that
they know you you are constantly having
to say I am i I can be great I can be
whole I deserve love
I deserve wealth I deserve to be treated
fairly and I feel like if maybe if I
just show you just another way that that
is possible and has been
Don historically then maybe maybe maybe
your you'll believe it because there's
no indication that you believe it you
don't behave that way and look I'm
married to a white woman I have
beautiful friends who I know don't
subscribe to this but it is a pervasive
thing that comes at you from so many
different angles and so the reason why
when the script for gringo came that
which was a script that was I think
written for Will Ferrell and and you
know other comedians of that nature were
considered for it when I got it I I was
determined to play it partly because it
would never be written for a black
person if you are in a comedy as a black
person more often than not the comedy is
centered around race hmm so yes again
you are compartmentalized you are
subjected to being laughed at for the
thing that you can't help being and so
you then have to kind of lean into it
and go let me own it you know you talked
about things that are are difficult to
say an unpopular opinion I have that I
will go to my grave having is the fact
that black people feel like they've have
felt like they have to embrace the
n-word why because of a lack of power so
if you are going to bludgeon me day and
night
with something as violent as that word
the only way I can live with myself is
to take ownership of it and to and to
make it something I can live with so I'm
going to refer to my friends at it as
myself as it because there is nothing I
can do to expunge it so the only way I
take the power back is to internalize it
for myself
repurpose it repurpose it but I have my
son's coming home to me saying that
their white friends are asking them
they can have an n-word pass so that
they are allowed to call them that word
which typifies to me the fact that that
word still has power and no matter how
much you tell yourself as a black person
that it is different when a black person
uses it as opposed to a white person
using it it still has that power because
two people who tend to subjugate black
people it has that power
so you using it yourself it's just a
self-fulfilling prophecy they call
themselves that so I can call them that
it's the same thing that happens a lot
at the time with comedy is the same
thing that happens a lot with the images
we put out the music we put out you know
the way we refer to women the way we
refer to each other the way that we
refer to money it's a self of self
perpetuating prophecy of the things that
have kept us in a certain place and I
get it I get it because in my own way
I've had to do it as well
you know the roles I'm that's why I say
I don't have the privilege to just go
you know what screw it I want to go and
play Jason Bateman's best friend I want
to do that but it comes with such
connotation of being an addendum and
afterthought on the periphery which is
how you know we are consistently having
to live our lives so I feel like for me
someone who has a bit of a platform a
bit of notoriety yeah I'll give you I
tell you a story that film you talked
about queen of can't wait so yeah my my
my kids had seen me playing dr. King in
Selma they had been on set with me they
saw clearly that I was the protagonist
of that story I was at the center of
that narrative did they understand well
how old were they did they know they
were there were young girls six years
ago now so my eldest who's now 18 was 12
and then you know and and and so they
were younger but I'll never forget I had
done that film and then I got the call
from Disney they were gonna make this
film queen of cartway a beautiful script
and I said to my children I'm gonna do a
Disney film this film called Queen of
cartway and the first thing my eldest
son said to me is daddy
that's amazing are you gonna play the
best friend that's what he said word for
word age 12 so that's what he had been
watching so you talk about children
internalize the abuse of animals they
are internalizing that as well and not
just black kids white kids that's right
and so this is this is centuries of
self-perpetuating
cyclical systemic stuff that we are
imbibing that has to manifest in the way
we behave so again
unconscious for people that you get
defensive and you know Robyn D'Angelo
talks about this a lot who wrote white
fragility the defensive nough stood up
right you know and she's and she says
she's learned everything she's learned
about white fragility from white
progressives yes yes exactly if you
think that you are immune because you
have a black friend whatever defenses
you've put up to justify she it so
important to read that book because
she's saying like you were this was
inculcated in an subconscious way that
you don't even see right no one's saying
you're actively racist but we're now at
the point where you have to be actively
anti-racist right because silence is
complicity now and you know half the
signs at the March and I know because
this rhymes it sounds like a platitude
but it you know really when I saw it
it's silence is violence you know
there's other kinds of violence besides
just the violence that we saw in that
video violence is also not having access
to clean water lead in water is a form
of violence thinking that black women
have a lower pain tolerant that is
violence right the daily stressors the
you know bringing up me to earlier and I
was kind of reluctant to bring this up
but III think those days are over
anything that feels uncomfortable you
have to say it and if you're wrong you
will learn something I didn't come
forward against a lot of my abusers
publicly because and I know a lot of
people that didn't because they didn't
want it to be their first google search
they didn't want to be
by it and you know I we didn't want to
be martyrs we didn't want everyone to
know we were abused we didn't want to be
reach Rama ties so there were these two
conversations happening in my life of
like the people are like let's go after
let's out everyone and look and there
were some of us that were just like I'm
gonna do everything I can but I don't
want to go through with dealing with
this publicly being retraumatization
I think that we have to make sure right
now that black people are not cleaning
up the mess we made
and I was just talking to some people in
our business we're like yeah well we're
going to all our black employees and
we're asking them what the fucking week
right and you know let's voting I
believe should be a national holiday
like let's let's have these bigger
conversations about figuring out you
know how black people can very easily
vote like asking your employers to be
the whistle blower of a thing you know
what I mean like it's your job to go
educate yourself you know there's this
great and I'm gonna put these all in my
stories
besides you know we've talked about
patronizing black businesses there's
Eddie Moore jr. wrote a 21-day racial
equity habit building challenge I know
that sounds really corny but it is a
daily read a daily listen you know to
podcasts teaching wild white code-switch
break Dances with Wolves podcast black
like me see there's enough out there now
for you to do the work on your own
reaching out to your black friend and
saying how are you doing and like what
should i do like that's not their job to
now teach you it's your job I'm so to do
that and you know we do vote with our
wallets I'm sorry I know that sounds
like a cliche and a platitude and also
being know you've seen this a lot on
social media being comfortable about
being uncomfortable it's easy to say
that and like feel like you've done
something revolution
but Robin talks about how you've been
programmed in condition to have Rachel
Rachel Rachel imagine I'm gonna talk
about Rachel Cargill in a second you
didn't cause it but you benefited from
it
you didn't cause it no one's saying you
caused it get that out of here
right no one's saying you didn't date a
black guy right you don't I mean I've
heard that so much and you know that's
like saying married guys can't be sexist
right you can be married to a man who
hates women right absolutely you can
take a black guy and still have racial
bias that's a perfect analogy right so I
think it's just important to say these
gross shameful things and to white
people have to say them and I think
recognize what you just said about the
me to movement there is shame attached
to having been abused and marginalized
and there is a price to pay for calling
it out that's right historically you
know you're risking future employment
because this person's trouble yes this
person and ever and everyone's walking
on eggshells around you it's like then
they treat with kid gloves and pretend
like you're made of glass and pretend
like you're gonna sue everyone all the
time exactly I mean yeah I have no doubt
that in the wake of me - even if it's
subconscious there are people who would
resist employing an attractive woman
because what of what that may now do in
the workplace where as you know al-ahmad
men that would have been the thing to do
in the past and so when John boyega
beautifully spoke out at her at a rally
last week and said III I may never work
again or whatever but I'm gonna say what
I'm gonna that's a real thing that's a
real thing Phoebe Robinson when she was
on the podcast talked about how not only
just being in Hollywood and being the
only you know black woman in a room all
the time
she feels like she can't even take care
of herself in the workforce because she
constantly just has to not come off like
an angry black woman yeah so raising her
voice
having boundaries asking for what she
needs but what also happens so often is
they're the only one there you see that
that's also one of the traumas as you
know because Kevin Hart Denzel
Washington Sidney Poitier Idris Elba
they are outliers they are not the norm
and so that then they become the example
of what's possible but that lady you're
talking about isn't surrounded by enough
people like her to not feel like oh if I
if I speak up I'm alone so I'm gonna be
single that if there's a group of you
you don't even you don't even think
about about requesting because you know
you have your back we're gonna make you
not feel if I were to say that I'd be
the badass boss right who stood I'd be
the protector and people would respect
me more right I would not be the problem
right exactly
and and these are all things that have
been institutionalized
and they become part of people's look we
all have bias that that's something to
also state because you know even in the
civil rights movement they were sexist
they were huge you know they have a
woman who I mean Coretta Scott King a
lot of what dr. King did was her idea
yeah and just at that time in history it
just wasn't for a woman to be front and
center and so so you can you can be a
good person and have these underlying
things that marginalize other people you
can be a lovely white person who doesn't
realize that you are part of something
systemically that is keeping other black
people from progressing you know and and
and that that's why I say the
acknowledgment of it is actually one of
the best things you can do I think is to
just acknowledge it and leave it there I
am aware there is a problem with them I
want you to know that I am now fully
aware of the problem that in and of
itself is healing because you know look
I'm I'm a Christian and one of the
things that I have really
ruggle dwith in the midst of all of this
is the fact that the church has not
joined with this moment in a spirit of
repentance if there is a consensus that
something is wrong if there is a
consensus that remorse is one of the
best things you can have when there is
an admission of wrong what that in and
of itself would just be hugely healing
we've seen it in countries like Germany
where you know they have decided what
happened to Auschwitz what happened
during the second it was just wrong and
their society has changed as a result
America's pride has just meant that
there has not been a consensus that this
is wrong so the word reparations doesn't
even connect right do you know what I
mean it's like what what do you mean
reparations want me to hear your memo I
didn't have slaves exactly exactly but
if you it's so hard to break down the
fact that this country was built on the
flat on the backs of black people and
they're so therefore we should share in
the wealth and so much of the the the
the economic poverty of the lack of
health care of the of the ghettos that
we end up living in of the police
brutality we're suffering is because we
have no power we have no power to be
able to politically say you must do this
because we don't have banks we don't
have the politicians who have that who
have the the clout or the power or the
backing financial backing that means you
have to look at me so in this moment all
we have is the power of the people the
all those marches we suddenly have a bit
of power and politics has that
regardless of who's who's president you
have to acknowledge that something is
happening that you cannot ignore and you
know people talk about the obviously
economic contributions of slavery I've
been learning a lot about the medical
contributions against black people as
well of course and it made me think of
Bill Clinton whom I have many problems
with
did apologize I tweeted the other day
for the Tuskegee syphilis experiments
yes you know that went on for truly 50
years they took about 400 black men who
they knew had syphilis that they were
pretending they were giving care to and
watched them die so they could dissect
their bodies you know the woman that
finally sort of exposed it you know said
something in the video where she said
after they dissected three men that
should have been enough like from a
medical perspective that's all you
needed to know to know that this was not
affecting black and white people
differently that's all you needed I was
looking up J Marion Sims who's actually
had a statue in Central Park up to two
years ago who was a guyhnic guyhnic
illogical surgeon gynecologist who
experimented mostly on slave women
surgeries with no anesthesia you know
and I think it's important that when we
talk about you know the pandemic causing
disproportionate Cova cases in black
people in general the health of black
people this inherited trauma and
inherited fear of the medical system
imagine being afraid to go to the doctor
because of the you know epigenetics I
talked about on this podcast all the
time and and I was reading about so
horrible you know as everyone probably
knows that slaves if they didn't clean
the amount of cotton they need to clean
in the ten hours they would get whipped
pregnant women were no exception and
they would dig holes in the ground for
them to lie on their stomachs to still
be whipped when they had we're carrying
a child and you know epigenetic
imprinting I think it's so important to
talk about this a little bit from a
biological perspective is the chemicals
neuro chemicals that you emit when
you're pregnant your baby is going to
become addicted to right the adrenaline
cortisol fear and we've talked about
epigenetics and how you know the study
in lab mice that they were electrocuted
that I'm for animal experiments but just
stick with me here see in the comments
that when they electrocuted these mice
and had them simultaneously smell cherry
blossoms their offspring when exposed to
the smell of cherry blossoms ran to the
other side of the cage right babies are
they recoil when they see a picture of a
spider even though they don't know what
a spider is that's an inherited fear
that is imprinted on your DNA you know
we have to talk about the fear that has
been imprinted the fear of going to the
doctor because this is my third time
saying it but black women are four times
more likely to die in childbirth and
half of the medical community believes
that they have a higher pain tolerance
and if we believe in what you just said
if the fear can work its way into you in
that way so can the privileged yeah
that's that that's mannan to an
atmosphere and so it's not your fault
you know when when black people keep on
saying we didn't create this it's not
down to us to fix it it's not that white
people who are now alive created it but
if you benefit from it and you have the
power to redress the balance and you can
acknowledge is why I say acknowledgement
is actually key which is what's so
beautiful about this movie it's the
problem unless you acknowledge that's
probably exactly and I personally would
say even if it's symbolic to talk about
repentance we we raise our kids to say
I'm sorry
it has an effect it actually has enough
it matters when my kids gone so no no
what did you say yeah and look someone
in the eye it because why it's as much
for you as it is for them it's the same
effect as saying to someone I love you
while looking them in the eye you are
transferring a truth from spirit to
spirit that is being internalized and is
going to affect the way you see yourself
the other person and the world around
you and what happens when you don't
acknowledge what's going on
is shame exact and it corrodes your
dignity your integrity and your
self-esteem right we're only as sick as
the secrets we keep right so when you
are holding these secrets you are
getting sicker as well absolutely you
can release that chain by admitting I
fucked up that was wrong
and that has to come from humility and I
there's a saying you can only be humbled
if you lack humility so Twitter the the
the the that fear that comes in when you
say to someone that that their white
privilege is pride the pride of being
humbled why because you lack humility so
that's something just to recognize that
white privilege comes with an
internalizing of a lack of humility
because when you have power when you
walk into the world and everything is
that your display against that its
inherent and we all feel it I feel it as
a successful actor you feel it when
you're all dressed up and people are
looking at you if there is a power that
comes with a certain way that other
people interact with you status and you
feel it when someone doesn't have that
despite their power it's the most
attractive thing it's the most welcoming
thing and that's what we're asking you
know this woman
who did this video her name's Kimberly
that went viral
Emily Jones who said you you better be
happy we're asking for equality and
about bringing revenge I mean and that's
that for me again another controversial
statement I truly believe America's
obsession with guns is that there is a
fear that this wound this sin this thing
baked into America as a society means
that black people let's one one we're
gonna rise we're gonna revolt we're
gonna come and kill you in your beds
there is a fear of that yeah and that is
why there is this consistent obsession
with armament someone posted the other
day if you guys know who it is put
in the comments so I can give credit but
said we're not protesting to start a
race where were protesting 2n1
absolutely we've been at war emotional
warfare health warfare there's a Harriet
Washington wrote a book called the
Medical apartheid and she talks about
yatra phobia fear of the healer right
and fannie lou hamer who activists
didn't you see right I'm gonna say this
I'm embarrassed I'm ashamed I did not
know about the forced sterilization of
black women yeah I didn't I didn't know
about that I can blame all the schools I
went to I can blame the people I follow
but like that blame falls on me and I'm
an adult
and it's my job to get this information
when black children went from quote
profitable to a nuisance women would go
in for procedures and would get
hysterectomy without their consent a
hundred and fifty thousand women were
sterilized without their consent how
does that not traumatize an entire
that's America and that's in living
memory that's a memory and so again I
think if you don't have humility you
don't have the ears to hear again I'll
talk about covert softening our hearts
you know we we've all been home going
when is this gonna end what's gonna
happen people who have built their lives
on this very American obsession wealth
you know I think in one day I can't
remember how many millionaires we lost
people just and so we were softened to
it we lost enough our white people had
fear of something exactly exactly it was
intangible and right and sort of
ubiquitous and there was no solution in
sight right and they were told just wait
right just wait exactly the unbearable
anxiety that comes with oh no it'll come
yeah I don't know what's gonna come the
vaccines gonna come yeah or whatever it
is the vaccine might kill you yeah but
it's coming which is what they were
protesting which is what the white
people were protesting that got the
states to open think about it that wait
dr. King talks about it every civil
rights activist has talked about it
enough with the way and it's been a four
hundred and one year wait I'm sure you
know this quote having played dr. King
this is in letter from the Birmingham
jail for years now I have heard the word
wait it rings in the ear of every Negro
with piercing familiarity this wait has
almost always meant never we must come
to see with one of our distinguished
jurist that justice too long delayed is
justice denied and it makes you sick I
mean physically there is sickness in
your body from that waiting because the
same general anxiety and it becomes
corrosive this week the reason I spent
so much of a last week crying I didn't
realize how deep the wounds were you
know I talked about this in a poster I
can i I was reading something over the
weekend they were saying the scars of
slavery and I think we need to say that
wounds of slavery because they've not
healed over that's that's perfect right
that's perfect and you cannot put a
band-aid on a bullet wound you it is it
is it is it is gangrenous it is so
painful i you know i put a post out last
week about my dad and what he had
suffered in the 1670s in the UK people
checking for his tale people throwing
hot coffee in his face spitting at him
these are things that he my dad is a
transcendent human being has no
bitterness in his body and as a result I
sort of heard those stories and was just
like oh gosh that was terrible what they
did thank God I wasn't alive then right
right until I started experiencing
things I was like that's that's not
that's not okay
that that I am being told to my face
when I went when I III I go with a
certain project white people aren't
ready
to see that literally I have had
situations true story I did a film
called captive and and there's a
character in there it was based on a
real character black guy is a big news
story went to some of the producers went
to a major studio to see if they wanted
to make it we loved this story but it
would just be so great the character the
guy was named as Brian Nichols was so
great we could make this character white
they knew it was a true story and I
don't even understand where how I did a
film called nightingale that my friend
Elliot Lester directed we wanted to get
financing for it so he went to can to
try and raise money the sales agent one
of the first sales agent he took this
film would be it's a great script but
you've really hampered yourself by
having a black lead this this is yeah oh
my god oh I could I can't tell you about
yesterday I mean like I mean there there
are things still with us and we are in a
moment now where people feel that they
are going to be held accountable to go
back to the me to movement which is and
it's a good one to reference because it
brought about systemic change which is
built upon accountability and a seeding
of power mm-hmm women have been given
just a bit more power and the part of
their power is the whistleblower factor
which if I'm a happy to be wrong that
wouldn't have happened without Twitter
absolutely that was never gonna happen
any other way and something I saw in
social the other day is to be clear to
be very clear they did not arrest that
cop because they saw the video they
arrested it cuz we saw the video
absolutely absolutely power where is the
power shifting at any given moment ever
Lena okay again this is one of those
situations where I do not need to read
the
as always I actually use the product
remember the ever Lane shirt and blazer
I ordered yeah I remember I wore it on a
talk show and I looked sharp as hell did
I not just look very Annie Hall very
Annie Hall it's hard to do this when
you're not here Benton I feel like
you're not taking my nonverbal cues very
well would you buy a t-shirt for $50 if
you knew it only costs $7 to make I
wouldn't
that's dark that's exploitative that's
dishonest
that's called a sham that's what we call
the goddamn sham ever Lane you never
overpay with quality clothes
sorry Benton I just silenced you I'm
abusing my power ever Lane
only makes premium essentials using the
finest materials without traditional
markups from the materials they use to
the ethical factories they work with
this is important okay we don't blind by
blood diamonds and we don't buy blood
Blazers I'm in trouble for that for sure
no matter your style or preference ever
Lane's clothes look better cost less and
last longer this is actually this is
true I wear that blazer in New York for
like five days straight each time with a
different shirt and I look cute as hell
classic essentials like their cotton
crew t-shirt I ordered one and what what
do you what's the color like it like a
brown like a tawny toffee brown the one
that I got that t-shirt the crewneck
yeah so I always get compliments on it
and it's a t-shirt so the color is just
so good anyway
versatile simple stylish and made from
quality materials this is all true and
freaking affordable have you been on web
sites recently Blazers or like $400 what
ever heard of the internet wild out
there I'm just saying why are jeans all
of a sudden $3,300 yeah I don't know
they're jeans what are we doing why our
twill Blazers $600 what's hot on sale
for 400 that's not a sale it's still a
scam should be paying this much silly I
will just can I just say cuz you sound
like you're in a submarine ever ever
lame dot-com slash Whitney ever Lane
dot-com slash Whitney also they're not
telling me to say this you can check my
computer screen follow their Instagram
because everything is cute as hell and
you can just see everything on their
Instagram I follow them so don't
embarrass yourself look cute you have no
excuse not to look adorable you have no
excuse not to look professional crisp
clean dapper debonair dare I say
effortlessly chic what are you doing
where we are now working with layered
superfood thank you Chris
this was in here they didn't send it to
me I bought it with my own cake layered
superfood I'm not even I'm gonna have to
look at the copy at some point but I'm
closing my computer this stuff superfood
creamer cacao a cook huh why did I just
turn into Bryan Callen cacao dude I put
this in my coffee every morning
by the way Joe Rogan also uses it so if
you don't trust me I know that you'll
trust him at least don't you just be the
ABS over we can use
[Laughter]
it's so good okay so they use coconut
milk powder organic coconut sugar do you
guys how much trash you put in your
coffee with the sugar with the milk with
the soy milk that's got the hormones in
it and the tree your just drink I mean
it's you're drinking a milkshake in the
morning right yeah I mean you're
drinking some of them are 800 calories
like you're just having whipped cream on
your coke cinnamon caramel macchiato no
no more your delicious sweet dessert
coffee can be healthy Laird Hamilton did
it famous surfer famous athlete he works
out underwater with kettlebells 12 feet
in the deep end do whatever he does he
made this I'd buy it but there's tons of
them I should now I should probably read
you'll only find real plant-based
ingredients like coconut milk powder
coconut sugar extra virgin coconut oil
and Aquaman which is a calcium derived
from sea algae it's all healthy okay
Gabby Reece is involved have you seen
her body recently look up Gabby Reece
and net I dare you not to buy this
unbelievable learn superfood never uses
preservatives processed sugar or
artificial ingredients you simply stir
Benton already said this power froth
their creamer into your coffee or tea
and you're good to go
superfood creamers come in delicious
flavors like original I have the
original one
cacao sometimes I just mix it with soy
milk and I don't even do it with coffee
because it's already got caffeine in it
to me tumeric is it tumeric or tumeric
never never are you sure yeah is that
the way people in Tennessee pronounce it
or is that the way it's pronounced it's
true to my critique and chocolate mint I
do the chocolate I have the chocolate
mint downstairs it's freaking delicious
wide variety of their products including
insta fuel instant coffee that's what I
just put in the soy milk high altitude
grown organic coffee beans hydrate
coconut water you can just put all those
flavored water scams out there that are
just pure sugar they have a
powder that you put into your water that
makes it more hydrating nah this is why
my skin looks like this you guys always
ask I'm hydrated by this go-to layered
superfood calm / Whitney enter promo
code Whitney and your me at 20% off
that's amazing your first purchase promo
code Whitney for 20% off your first
purchase at layered la IRD you should
know how to spell Laird Hamilton's name
he's been famous for a while now
Laird superfood dot-com am I loved is I
mean am I legally allowed to say you
look like Gabby Reece I'm saying I'm
saying this whatever she puts in her
body you should also put in your body
just do whatever she does we're not
gonna do it in this in this interview
which I loving by the way but you know
white privilege to white people just
hear me on this it is not a reprimand in
the same way that black lives matter is
a statement of fact white privilege is
just a statement of fact and it's just
something that we have got to now
internalize and try and move on from in
a way that hints at the best of us
that's all that's all that's all that's
all with us and if I may this is I'm
quoting Robyn D'Angelo quite a bit
author of white fragility which is
delightfully sold out on Amazon love to
see it for those saying there's reverse
racism there's a little bit when you
people get defensive they want to say
that maybe you're the director that is
why she is so scathing of those who
claim reverse racism exists people of
color can show presidents against white
people it is equally you know it is what
it is but this form of discrimination
does not come with systemic privilege
and so is not racism per the modern
definition it's not backed up by
full institutions benefitting you
everyday you can deal with reverse
racism and then go outside and put a
hoodie on and walk home without anxiety
someone put this to me perfectly
yesterday they say when when we were
talking about the power of words and the
N word cuts so deep mm-hmm there isn't
there isn't a white but there isn't a
word no force not a word talk to white
people client isn't that in that that
but specifically attributable to the
white race as a a curse Kanzi doesn't
absolutely it does
cracker doesn't it has no power behind
it it has no history behind it so it
speaks to that this point which is
reverse racism it's about power there is
power in that word there is power in
hearing that word there is power in
saying that word because of its history
and how it was used through history and
it's like well that that takes nothing
from me when you use the n-word towards
me it's a reminder of what's been taken
from me and of what you are continuing
to take from me which is my dignity
that's right in the moment and I'm just
gonna read a couple more of these quotes
and you can expound on them or not
racism is a white problem it was
constructed and created by white people
and ultimately as the responsibility
lies with the right people white people
for too long we've looked at it as if it
was someone else's problem as if it was
created in a vacuum that's what she's
doing you know Leila sad wrote even good
allies are probably complicit those
police officers behind George Floyd just
stood there and did nothing
mushiya encourages readers to
investigate the relationship to a number
of topics including cultural
appropriation white centric feminism I'm
gonna say it I went to the women's March
the first women's March didn't see one
black woman right and I was like what's
happening called a black girl friend of
mine she went yeah no you skip the line
in March there were five black women
there holding signs that said white
women or white Trump as president racist
stereotypes
you know you touch on a little bit with
the best friend Brandon Goodman talks
about watch what media you consume if
you're seeing a poorly sketched
character they need you know in the
shows you watch the shows you're binging
watch what you click on watch what you
give your business to you know and to
speak to that first point about the sort
of the notion of I can't remember what
you said where there's reverse races in
order it's like it's like what happens
to a raped woman and and and no it's not
the reverse races and what was the point
you just before just now the white
centric feminism no the one before that
cultural appropriation yes yeah and
sorry one of those biggest signs I saw
at the March was love black people the
same way you love black culture
right absolutely please but it's like
when a raped woman is is told yeah well
if you hadn't worn that skirt or maybe
some of it you're asking or your fault
yeah it's it's this it's the same thing
that you were you were you were asking
for I mean I it's a it's wrong but
there's something about you that
probably and it's like can we just agree
that rape is wrong right
can we disagree that what's happening to
black men and women there isn't a gray
area here isn't an up fur see that a and
again that's the thing with the George
Floyd video he was not resisting you
know Eric Ghana there's five men who
would the first thing they say uh he was
selling he was selling illegal
cigarettes or whatever the
criminalization of Mike Brown
instantaneously or whatever it's just
like does that mean they were just
talking about this someone is trying to
get some shit going on Twitter that
George Floyd was involved in the porn
industry even if he was does that mean
we should go into the valley right now
and just start
killing everyone good boy in this
station even if he was a criminal
rat shouldn't have happened exactly
exactly if that if we had seen that
happening in a prison right we should
still be outraged but this is what gets
wheeled out all the time but only in
relation to black people can you just
imagine if if if Derrick Chauvin had
done that to a white woman the country
would be on fire would we even be having
moans by pink charge would be currently
filmed during the covetous Rosie's
literally the outrage which which shows
you how we have compartmentalized
different people because why is it any
different if we say life is precious
life shouldn't be taken unjustly life
shouldn't be taken by law enforcement
why why should it be different if it
were a white woman or even say a white
man a white woman who had that cops knee
on her neck for 8 minutes and 46 seconds
it would be a dying guess as the cops
would have intervened before it was 8
minutes 46 absent which which would have
gone on about 20 everything but that's
the point
let me go further a white woman who was
a criminal right had just done something
criminal that everyone - absolutely
absolutely
a white woman who was a murderer yep you
know it would it would a white murderer
yeah
yes wouldn't go to a fancy prison yeah
get a biopic well look what they did to
the guy who shot shut up a manual choke
Chapel you know I think eight nine
people yet they took him to Burger King
after arresting him I mean it's so there
is something about this you know as a
black person you kind of go the ignorant
that you sometimes see feels willful it
feels like you are yeah you you are how
can how am I expressing this to you and
there is a sort of I can see you're not
it's not working
it's way into you and that is the moment
we are in for whatever reason kovat
pandemic the image that whatever these
young people are no joke I mean you know
they really give me hope for the future
yes yeah and and they are giving us
something dr. King didn't have no other
movement against injustice whether it's
the feminist movement the civil rights
movement it has not been this pervasive
in terms of the demographics that are
showing up and that is different and if
I may you don't get points for that you
go you have to show up right you can't I
mean posting is very important I I you
know I know I make fun of performative
activism and self certain what seems
self-serving and for honestly like I
think for the past week certainly a
selfie of you partying at the beach like
just don't post that please because to
me that says it's normalizing something
it's like that doesn't apply to me you
know and by the way Whitney please don't
post images of cops white cops hugging
black people because even though that's
a beautiful image in isolation that's
not the point
no there's no no with this one hunt one
we're good yeah no this one hugged a
black person what's actually happening
in America is the knee on the neck
that's what's actually happening not
this outlier you know random thing that
is only happening it is not the story of
policing in America there are great cops
in America there are people there are
cops who have love in their heart but
that is a privilege scratching that itch
to make yourself feel better please
don't let us go back to a comfortable
place too quickly with that's that's
that's the key and I and I'm gonna read
something else from a letter from a
Birmingham jail dr. King you probably
know this by heart nonviolent direct
action seeks to create such a crisis and
foster such attention that a community
which has constantly refused
to negotiate is forced to confront the
issue I'm not afraid of the word tension
there's a type of constructive
nonviolent tension which is necessary
for growth we have to keep the tension
this is tense it's stressful it's
exhausting we're in a pandemic it's a
lot I know it's it's a it's hard to look
at I didn't I didn't want it took me a
couple days to finish the George Floyd
video yeah but it's not for my
entertainment I'm not meant to feel good
about it it's not meant to be an
enjoyable experience like you have to
willfully expose yourself to that in
order to shake out of your comfort you
have to be out of your comfort zone
right now and allowing yourself to feel
that tension if it is not a tension that
you have historically had to deal with
is a huge part of solving the problem
because what I do for a living the
images we put on screen what we are
looking to create whether it's a comedy
a horror film an action film a biopic
you are looking to elicit empathy my job
is to make you feel like you are me
that's my job so that if I'm playing the
protagonist you feel like you are
experiencing what I'm going through that
is the power of cinema and so in this
moment to feel that tension in the same
way you hopefully feel the tension dr.
King is feeling when you watch Selma or
to feel what that that that that kid is
going through when she's playing chess
and queen of cart way and you feel
empathy for an 11 year old kid in in a
slum in Uganda or an activist in 1965
who you have no shared experience with
but you feel that tension that is the
power of cinema and it makes you be more
human it opens your heart so don't run
away from this tension because you have
to feel it in order to feel energized to
stop other people having to deal with it
your your your activism when it comes to
animal rights it's because so it's not
that that that
that dog or that hole so that whatever
is is is human
it's just compassionate its but I I did
the wrong thing for a long time right I
used to ride horses with the bed and I
used to do go on carriage like I used to
do all the stuff that I am now against I
didn't know and I used to beat myself up
for it and be like oh god I used to
train horses and break them in this I
just I didn't know because I was taught
you're white and you can do whatever the
fuck you want whenever the fuck you want
right and it doesn't matter if you're
subjugating something that's powerless
and voiceless it doesn't matter you're
white and you get to do that right
that's what I learned right and then I
saw to your point I saw images I
couldn't unsee yes exactly and I saw how
breaking animals happen I saw how the
circus happens and I saw how you get a
bear to balance on a beach ball how you
get him to say I saw those videos right
and I couldn't unsee them exactly and I
yes do I have nightmares yes I do
of course I do I'm I don't wish that
hippocampus for everyone but when it
comes to human beings we have to update
our software what you just said there is
perfect you didn't know and that's okay
and that's okay to acknowledge but it is
something once you do know please yeah
grow from please don't let don't then
have that knowledge and pretend you
don't and that's the thing that makes it
exhausting and willful I want to say
something really I know we brought up
defund the police when I first heard it
I didn't understand it I had to do a
deep dive and what that meant again and
Brittany packed met Cunningham puts it
beautifully when she talks about where
the funds would actually go again access
to affordable homes access to
after-school programs mental health
programs redistributing the wealth in
other ways right and in Eugene Oregon
they did something called the cahoots
program after much protesting against
the police where mental health
responders go to the scene first and
deescalate the situation
and there was a 20 to 30% reduction of
police shootings they also outlawed
chokeholds killings have gone down since
that so I guess I just want to say like
this war fighting works it does work
we're just not doing enough of it right
you know pressure works tension does
work right and I again like and I hope
this doesn't come off flippant but at
the march esterday I was just look
around I was like if black people could
have done this without white people it
would have been done so long ago
absolutely but we didn't we didn't and
we still don't have the power to move
the needle and look I'm learning when I
first heard defund the police and and to
be perfectly frank I've heard some
people say abolish the police now I
don't personally subscribe to yeah yeah
yeah but defund the police in exactly
the way you've just read it out it only
makes sense I mean it was it was sort of
highlighted to me yesterday in in what
we do you know you're you're driving
through public streets while you're
filming who escorts you it's the cops
now that creates a certain atmosphere if
there are homeless people loitering
under a bridge or sleeping under a
bridge who they would you call you call
the police but if there's someone
mentally ill walking around causing
anorak who do you call the police and
and they are simply not equipped so you
know there are people doing this
incredibly dangerous job for them but
also for other people if they are now
being grafted into a culture that is
militarized which is the other side of
defund the police you don't need tanks
you don't need these huge guns when it's
a it's a fraction of what you do is
actually going into violent crime
situations so much of what you do is not
that so why are we Miller
rising the police again it goes into
this foundational sin in America this
paranoia about being I think taken to
task for what is sort of unfortunately
under the surface of American life this
paranoia about being called out about
things that have been done you know
marginalized people going enough
yeah and you see it playing out on
American streets and I tell you what if
we didn't all have these phones filming
everything you know I mean that that's
what caused Bloody Sunday is that there
were journalists hiding and capturing
those image seventeen-year-old who
recorded George Floyd right now getting
shit for not stepping in seventeen years
old how can you even say that child when
when a huge guy like murder murder is
murdering yeah you need to charge a
police officer right murdering with
three other police officers with guns
flanking them what on earth are you
supposed to to do but they know that
they know that's again I'm saying again
and again and again power mm-hmm
ego look at your ego see when your ego
speaks up because my ego speaks up
sometimes right yeah and you just have
to be able to observe your ego I'm not
racist right but I black friends right
it's like a it's like a habit you know
it's a way that we rationalize because
we don't want to feel like no one wants
to feel like they fucked up no one wants
to be I think when people say you have
white privilege it's in some we feel
attacked yeah we feel like you know
you're telling me I'm bad yeah and the
we're so conditioned to avoid shame and
this perfectionism like no one's
expecting you to do this you know
perfectly you know and I think it's just
important to fill in the blanks of your
education our education has failed us
usually hugely you know Britney talks a
lot about we need more black teachers
frankly
defund the police some of that those
resources can help make teaching a job
that's attractive to more people we
don't even know what we're surrounded by
the Edmund Pettus Bridge that is
featured in the film Selma that dr. King
and all of those people marched over is
named after the Grand Dragon of the Ku
Klux Klan in the 1800s and it is still
the name of that bridge in Selma Alabama
that is now pretty predominantly black I
grew up a little bit in Virginia there's
a city called Lynchburg right next to
Salem right next to Roenick right I mean
we saw the Redskins I mean what do we
tie me knits just like it's so close
it's so ubiquitous and those things are
symbolic of how close it is literally
and spiritually so redlining didn't know
anything about that until Donahue see
Coates wrote about it in the case for
reparations which everyone should take a
gander on if you haven't already this
was something that happened to Chicago
preventing black families from getting
mortgages if you had to sign this
contract and if you didn't pay in a
certain amount of time they could just
take take your home from you basically
their contracts they didn't even
understand what they were signing half
the time it was so written in such a um
circuitous confusing serpentine way and
they were overcharged the average
overcharged was ten thousand dollars and
when we talk about reparations he was
mentioning as late as 2017 we were still
paying pensions to Civil War veterans we
we do pay right in North Carolina they
did reparations program against women
like a eugenics program I don't know if
nothing enough about it it's doable it's
doable
but there is no there is no appetite for
it because again like Kimberly Jones
said in Rosewood in Tulsa during
Reconstruction
these were all moments where black
people in America gained power and
affluence
and had to sort of build wealth on their
own because they weren't being embraced
by white America and what did we do in
every single one of those instances
after the Rica after ten years into
reconstruction Jim Crow laws were
introduced and decimated all of the
gains that were made after the Civil War
Tulsa burnt to the ground Rosewood burnt
to the ground because it is about again
power the redlining
is weak at that there is an under
there's a fundamental understanding in
America of what building wealth means
which is why in this country unlike
almost any other country your ability to
become president is driven by how much
money you have you can rear health care
right your school systems you know you
have presidential candidates who have to
raise a billion dollars in order to be
the most powerful person in the
millionaire's just can join like two
months before the debates right right
which which shows you that the the part
money and power plays in American life
and so part of that indignation I think
people feel when they are accused of
white privilege is because somewhere in
their psyche somewhere in their
subconscious they know that in order to
not be able to be accused of that there
has to be a redistribution of wealth and
power because that's the only point
beyond which you're not saying white
privilege is that we we all can live in
a gala terian meritocratic life but it
just doesn't exist and the founding
fathers what what this country is meant
to be built on it is it so much of it is
paradoxically a lie it's not how we
actually live our lives they're great
ideals that have enabled this country to
market itself as the police of the world
because it has this sort of moral sort
of overhanging
a feel to it but it's not what is being
played how do you go and fight a world
war in Europe again
people being marginalized and then black
people are part of fighting that war as
American soldiers and they come back and
it's white soldiers this way black
soldiers this way a segregated military
and you are going up against Hitler who
is burning Jews which i think is
important to understand and I have more
learning to do on this topic certainly
but when you know African Americans were
first put in the military they did not
return to a hero's welcome not just not
just with this segregation is that white
people were very concerned they're gonna
go over to other countries and see a
lack of segregation and then the black
men in uniform we're thought of as too
proud having seen less subjugation other
places and they're gonna come back and
be harder to manage I did a film about
it Red Tails
you know the Tuskegee Airmen they first
there was a military study done that
proved that black people had smaller
brains than white people and so
therefore they shouldn't be given equal
duties in the military and the only
reason the Tuskegee Airmen were
eventually deployed is because America
hemorrhaged so many planes and fighter
pilots that the Tuskegee Airmen were
training for two years without being
deployed because they were deemed lesser
than they got so good in those two years
that they had a better record than any
other a flight infantry in the history
of that war and when they came back
exactly that the white the white pilots
went to ticker-tape and fanfare and
these these guys literally off the boat
there was a black owns blacks only exit
and I think it's important to really
educate ourselves white people on sort
of what happened when enslaved people
were set free quote unquote they were
sent out just by nothing and most you
know did not have health care did not
we're not able to take care of
themselves and we're getting syphilis
and dying passing
and what was taken from that just per
this like scientific basis of a lot of
this institutionalized systemic racism
that still is sort of in our hippocampus
in some way still haunts us the thought
was black people aren't as resilient
they aren't as healthy they're all it's
it's all propaganda and narratives that
unfortunately we all imbibe and take and
so you know what sometimes black people
internalize it as well you start to
believe the lie because you're told it
enough your name has been stolen from
you know you don't know where you came
from the inception the beginning of you
as a people as far as you know is
slavery and so you have
african-americans denigrating Africans
calling them African booty scratcher and
Kunta Kinte and nappy head and and these
so you you are you are you are trained
to hate yourself and where you came from
and so what do you then do you
internalize the fact that you are born
out of slavery subjugation
that's my beginning which is why the
name was stolen which is why the culture
was stolen it is to decimate everything
about any kind of self esteem self worth
you have to break it like you said about
breaking a horse you have to break it
eret break the spirit so that you can
subjugate the person and so inevitably
you're gonna you're gonna start
believing some of this if that's all you
see and then you get rewarded for your
low salt it starts to work for you right
when you make yourself small and walk on
eggshells and talk a certain way and
don't offend anybody and dress a certain
way it starts working for you because it
makes white people feel comfortable
right and then oh well this is my
survival mechanism and then you you you
you speak out and you're angry you're an
angry black man you're not you know
please when you talk about when you're
when you're getting talking about a
black guy in a story just refrain from
saying he was a big black guy
you never say oh yeah I was at this barn
in his
big white guy you just don't it's but
it's part of this thing this this
internalized bias and racism where we a
big black guy signifies something as
opposed to just a guy and please don't
say that a black person is well-spoken
right or eloquent right with shock as if
it's an aberration right joy and I don't
know her work well joy deGruy I think I
pronounced that right talks about
post-traumatic slave syndrome sure an
article that outlines how the impact of
slavery was a significant trauma to
African American people which was
carried forward through successive
generations providing an explanation of
their current anxiety related conditions
poor health or maladaptive behaviors
vacant esteem insufficient development
of primary esteem along with feelings of
hopelessness depression and a general
self-destructive outlook marked
propensity for anger or violence racist
socialization and internalized racism
distorted self-concept
african-american men disproportionately
suffer with the depression the amount of
guys I've talked to the fight to leave
the house especially around this issue
of policing the fear you carry the
posture you feel you need to have yes in
order to just tell yourself that you are
of worth and have self-esteem you know
it is just you know I go back to what I
said if there were the levels of
exhaustion you feel around this stuff it
is and I think you know the amount of
people I've talked in the last week or
two who they're just holding on by a
thread yeah I've got to tell you and so
that's partly why and you know I resist
saying you know because I've I've I've
really appreciated people who've reached
out to me white friend
of mine who have reached out to me I
would not have done it privately only on
a public no but i but i but i i do
appreciate it but it is you know again
it's like it's like asking things of a
raped brutalized battered person and and
and and and then feeling like they say
rights right it's okay right I need you
to now do the work yeah and I and I get
it and it's part of the outreach and
it's part of the acknowledgement and
it's a part of the linking arms and
you're right people have to have to not
just talk they have to do but you know
to we've talked a lot about the things
that haven't been done look there
this is why I talk about this country as
a as an experiment that is in the midst
of of something incredibly redemptive
and has the potential to be because we
all know people who have made really bad
choices in life and sometimes when they
heal from those things when they
rehabilitate from those things not only
do they become transcendent human beings
what they have learnt through what they
went through becomes so edifying for
other people and America for better or
for worse is a country that has the
attention of the world these
demonstrations in Germany and and and in
the goodness I mean black lives matter
being on the houses of parliament in
London I cannot even tell you how
bizarre and extraordinary that is that
it has permeated to that degree that is
something truly my brother yeah my
brother still lives there who has faced
terrible things you know but for America
to take the opportunity to actually be a
good example as opposed to foisting
itself upon the world as a
good example as the police to the world
to actually do that amp for it to be a
people led movement what would would be
something that I think would be
redemptive beyond imagining because it
is possible it is possible because this
country does have you know the reason I
live here is because there is no greater
country in the world for opportunity I'm
never gonna get to play the equivalent
of dr. King in the UK or anywhere else
on the planet that also happens here
Obama also happens here Oprah also
happens here that is part of what is
possible here but you you you just gotta
just just share just share benefits you
to share absolutely do it for selfish
reasons yeah if everyone in this country
is truly benefiting from what this
country has by way of resources by way
of of of wealth I mean there's just no
stopping it's interesting tonight and I
don't remember what that there's some
official term for this but I think that
with the pandemic - people that are able
to quarantine and you know mansions or
whatever and have people run errands for
them I think this is one of the first
times in history at least in our
lifetime
where people are realizing everyone's
health care is now my problem right
because I can catch this from anyone
right it used to be like I have my
health care you don't have health care
it's not my problem right now if
something is airborne and contagious
everybody's health is your problem right
right right
because it's an invisible virus so I
think that to just expound upon your
metaphor earlier like this is everyone's
problem it's making everyone sick right
everyone's like Tiffany Haddish was on
them I had she live the other day and it
just broke my heart because she was just
sort of crying about how her mom used to
tell her that she needed to become
self-sufficient
in case the man she was with didn't come
home at night like you have to be okay
on your own because you don't know where
as I learned you need to be
self-sufficient take care of yourself so
you never have to rely on a man right
not he might not come home one day
because he was wearing his hoodie wrong
or went to birdwatch at the wrong time
right you know yeah so I think um you
know everyone I mentioned I'm gonna post
in stories there's only a couple of
things because I know you have to get
back to your life you have things and I
true leader ever it's all good um I I
just want to remind everyone that
sometimes the most progressive people
can be the most sanctimonious about all
this I think that's just important and
you know Robyn D'Angelo also says just
cuz you have an opinion doesn't mean
it's an informed opinion right I thought
it was so much progress just like have
an opinion and like I'm outspoken it
doesn't necessarily mean it's um a
cogent one just because you don't see it
it doesn't mean it isn't there because
we've been conditioned not to see it
because it's uncomfortable racism isn't
just your thoughts people wanna say well
I'm not racist that's not okay like it's
a system of laws and economic
institutions and programming and tax
brackets and laws like you're not off
the hook because you just said you're
not racist right there you know I also I
was gonna ask and I think you've already
said it I just want to ask one last time
like does this feel different it is
different again for a black person
watching the George Floyd murder what
you're used to is like we've said a a
denigration of the murdered person's
character is that the playbook gets
wheeled out and so it's it's that that
that's that's the first thing that
happens the cops get to go home where
else where in which other part of life
do you have you murdered someone you get
to go home before
their narrative they come back they oh
there was a there was a there was a gun
there was oh they went for their gut
that that is not on the table yes he had
asthma whatever right there that's not
on the table this time and so
third-degree murder is part of the
playbook
because it can then be dropped to
manslaughter and then even degraded
beyond them
the difference here going from third
degree murder to second degree murder
degree murder that I've never seen and
I've spoken to people who are
knowledgeable you've never seen an
upgrading mm-hmm in this situation when
you want to say the posting on social
media doesn't help you are wrong you
were absolutely wrong because that was
that was a people driven yeah a pressure
pressure driven a decision if you can't
donate some where you can create
pressure absolutely followers ten
followers I don't care how many
followers you have the other thing I've
never seen is for cops being I mean all
those cops in the Rodney King they don't
just just just booked all of them you
know but for for aiding and abetting
murder that's that's new yeah
these marches are new this conversation
we're having is new a white privilege
being something admitting I'm wrong
about something is new well let's fit
this is the biggest miracle of war you
guys I don't know it everything yeah
miracles can his know so it does feel
different I mean Minneapolis like we
like we said yesterday deciding to
deconstruct their what I read in the New
York Times is that they don't even think
reform is enough they've got to kind of
scrub it out and start again and I loved
the humility and we'll see what actually
happens humility of saying we don't know
what it'll be but we know this cannot be
right we still need browner tailors
exactly still more to do oh my goodness
there's so much to do but you know even
that the tasing of a
when it was his name Messiah young I
think in Atlanta the other day just him
and a girl just driving in Atlanta all
six cops in that instance I believe
charged that that we are we are in a new
moment and again like we've said about
the me to movement accountability a
Derek shovin if he arrested George Floyd
today would think twice yes that's right
about the way he treated him even with
18 complaints before this right this is
said a meal of a shower this is
something else we've got to address we
have to we have to be able to to have an
interaction with a cop see their name
and badge and that the number and be
able to go to a website and see that
there's 18 citations because that also
would change the narrative if if
instantaneously CNN Fox whoever was able
to say this cop did this today and these
are the citations he already has against
him do you think that anything will be
able to stick in terms of the the George
Floyd's character or criminality in in
the limited way that I can relate when
me to was happening and guys were
complaining sort of like the white
director you're talking to who's
complaining how hard it was for him to
get a job you know a lot of guys were
like oh so I can't like hug a woman at
work anymore
right and I'm like I don't care if this
is hard for you right I don't care it
like I don't I don't know what you feel
has been taken from you right right but
your entitlement and your loss of being
able to like call me honey is not is not
for me that's your problem to solve
right you know right your your police
officers feeling uncomfortable that
they're being watt that's not I don't
I've no sympathy for that no no it's not
something anyone needs feel bad about no
when your job is to protect and serve
that's right I mean these paradoxes just
exist so pervasively in our society to
protect and serve what we just saw there
is antithetical to that what black
people see day
there is antithetical to that and that
the whole thing of going back to defund
the police there are areas in which it
is unfair to be perfectly frank to be
asking the the police to protect and
serve you're not equipped to deal with
someone who's mentally ill on the on the
streets you're not a you know you
shouldn't be in a school making kids
feel like they're in a war zone from
when they're so young that is just not
and that that you're literally this
kattiline that we've been we've been
seeing happening with the cops then
walking in formation it is designed to
to elicit a certain reaction it is not
designed to de-escalate situation it is
specific you see that in war that is how
the army do it when they are going
against the enemy you know so again it's
willful to have that happening
especially in economically deprived
communities your tax dollars are paying
for these tanks right are unnecessary
right this is this affects you it's not
going to your public schools it's not
going to your after-school programs your
parks or your local hospitals or making
housing affordable or any of that shit
and I would go even further to say that
money is willfully being spent to deny
black people wealth or the ability to
build wealth you are creating silos
whereby wealth creation is impossible
food deserts like they can't get fresh
food so it's all fast food and so again
going back to why black and brown people
are disproportionately affected by this
stuff the diets are terrible because it
is constructed to do that when you go
back to these 150,000 women who were
being given hysterectomies without
without knowing there is a there again
slavery sharecropping prison industrial
complex the destruction of the black
body has been wove
into this country's history for so long
and it's a hard habit to shake and
sometimes you don't even realize or
recognize that you were a cog in the
wheel of that destruction whether it be
economically or to the physical body
itself it is just an undeniable fact
that is part of what this country was
built on the subjugation and murder of
other people's Native Americans black
people Mexican be in the Mexican
American War just you know tick tick
tick tick tick tick tick and Britain for
instance where I was born is not exempt
it was perfected on that tiny island and
exported to the world and sometimes you
know Britain takes this this
sanctimonious stance because it didn't
happen the only reason it didn't happen
on that tiny island is there's enough
space right to to do it and it has
barely any resources so it all happened
in Africa it will happened in that the
Caribbean these places that had
resources that built that place black
people built Britain as well those
jewels in the crown all that stuff where
did they come from that gold that oil
the UK doesn't have any of that stuff
Europe you know where there's the
Portuguese or the Belgians you know that
the decimation of that continent and
even some of the most progressive
countries in the world I'm talking to
you Amsterdam with the black Santa Claus
yep complicit do we so it's it's we're
not just talking about America we're not
just talking about here noses which is
why these protests are indeed worldwide
you know Judge George Floyd is a is a
jump-off for it and again beautiful to
see that in these places it's not just
black people but there are there are
white people waking up mm-hmm to the
fact that they've been beneficiaries of
this and that's what to your question
feels different you know to be abused to
be to
be used and abused and denigrated
consistently in this way it's a very
lonely feeling because you fish again
the shame and if you have any modicum of
success where you go in your head and
they they trade on this a the power
structures trade on this you are made to
feel like the one and then you get
celebrated as the one and then what
starts to happen the crabs in the barrel
syndrome anyone else coming and women
have this as well I've seen it at work
will you get a bit of success and you
know that you are rarefied for being
given that success and then you feel
like your success is dependent on other
people being kept down queen bee
syndrome exactly and so that is also
something that is a perfect part of this
machine that helps to keep a certain
demographic at the top design women and
I've talked about this because in some
cases no one's been meaner to me in this
business and women and I have
forgiveness because we forgive others
not because we deserve forgiveness or
they deserve forgiveness because we
deserve peace don't you mentioned before
they learned how to be powerful for men
yes
so it's gonna be clumsy for a while yes
soon and I mean it's gonna be a little
shaky as we're growing our sea legs yes
and the scarcity complex is still very
real and I'm seeing a lot of people
posting I'm a black man who's not going
to tear down another black man because
of this there can only be one of us one
at a time is amok and and this is the
beauty of this moment we are all
learning I mean ah my son who was
sobbing body heaves sobbing last week in
his room the week he graduated from high
school I was walking past his Roma
what's going I went into his room and he
was it was like someone had died and as
what what are you okay he just said I I
thought I didn't think
could happen to me and and and and in
that moment I thought what what do you
mean he said well you know we have up we
have a nice house and and you know we
live in a nice area and you know and my
eldest son has an English accent and he
thought I am ashamed to say daddy but I
have an English accent so I thought I'd
be able to say and they would they said
oh he said Joey didn't let George Floyd
speak they didn't even let him get his
words out so I may be in a situation
where I don't get to speak up for myself
and then this this this woman in New
York we go to New York all the time that
could have been me
and I it was so emasculating to not have
the words to comfort him it brutalized
me because we just sat there together
cuz I can't lie to him and give him a
playbook or advice on how to avoid that
it's just it can happen in Central Park
it can happen and it happens in the
streets of LA all the time it can it
just the crime is the color of your skin
and he said I'm confused daddy because I
am as black as I am white his mum's
white and he was like and and I and I'm
just categorized in this way he it was
just completely confused I'm of Nigerian
descent I'm British and but there's
nowhere that I know it's just optics
yeah I've made my decision about you
based on just a quick gander of pigment
pigment your one David your one thing
based on on a mindset centuries-old it's
so we're and we are always so fucking
weird yeah but you're a victim of it I'm
a victim of it we are all victims of it
it's it's it's it's the most
controversial thing I'm gonna say on
this podcast but Derrick Chauvin
a victim of it he imbibed and
internalized a system that turned him
into that and now his life is over yeah
he didn't win no but there are others
who feel like they want they've killed
they've murdered black people they
didn't go to prison they they they are
still working as cops and they think
they've won they think they've won but I
am sorry I am I am a deep believer in
the fact that the human spirit
ultimately has something good about it
and if you fly so in the face of that
there are things you will carry into old
age I I feel bad for you you know to be
carrying that and and the reason why
it's a controversial statement is
because you know the dehumanization of
Derek Chauvin is right because of how
dehumanized he was in his behavior but
he was cultivated because we are we can
I mean it is done outside the other day
on the podcast the this one rotten apple
thing you know is a way to get out of
your discomfort to get out of you know
the guilt in the shame or whatever and
done I'll put it so smoke is so deaf
didn't like if you go to the grocery
store and there's one bad apple like the
whole bag sketchy right you don't wanna
fuck with that right yeah right you know
right absolutely he's been enabled for
he's gotten away with this for a very
very long time and I would go I would go
further in a world of genetically
modified food if you have a system
whereby the food all of the food is is
is being produced in a system that is
not good for us we can still eat apples
and we can feel like we're eating
healthy food and feel like yeah I'm
having my five a day or whatever into
but the way we are creating it is wrong
there is
that culture of the the the the the
slave catcher the the save controller
there is there is there is there is a
whiff of that that has carried on that
has carried and whether you like it or
not there are people who are liberal
conservative whatever including the the
Amy Cooper's and the reason why I keep
on coming back to her is I'm sure you
guys all know she was the woman in
Central Park who had her dog off leash
and a bird watcher asked her can you
please pick your dog on a leash your
dogs always me on a fucking leash
and she called the cops she embodies
white privilege that that is that is
what that is in its embodiment and the
reason it came out in that moment was
fear she said I was sure and there have
been people who have said yeah but she
was scared but but fear as an emotion is
a is a moment of truth lot of
interesting stuff comes out when you are
scared and so to that to have that
instant and then go and make a statement
saying I'm not racist it is exactly what
where what what makes you just want to
set your hair on fire as a black person
because it's like to to do what you do
there is you if you ever have to say I'm
not racist you're already intriguing you
should never situation where you have to
say it then you're already yeah yeah and
so just just take with that moment and
make it systemic yeah just go I've
benefited from racism and I've probably
done some racist shit because I was
inculcated in me and how do I fix it and
look at the systems you can literally
transpose the numbers in the deaths from
kovat onto the prison industrial complex
you can literally trace in terms of you
know I think it's 50 something percent
we black and brown people and the prison
industrial complex and they're sixty
something percent of the over a hundred
thousand people who have nada you know
so the
the traces that the hemisphere of it it
infiltrates everything including us you
said it perfectly that earlier earlier
on which is that we're gonna say things
and get them wrong but much better to
say them get them wrong and kind of and
be and be humble enough to go by the way
that's offensive
just just one I just went oh my god
thank you for telling me no one's told
me that before right thank you and I'm
sorry I put you in a situation where you
have to tell me right that sucks
and we're it's over yeah exactly it's
over in any good relation I'm so that's
what how grateful that you told me that
right I have food in my teeth
tell me right isn't that what great
friendships up no people don't tell you
have food in your teeth yeah you don't
care about me you want me to keep
embarrassing myself and offending people
exactly the person who's like he needs
to take a gum right trust me exactly
literally thank you yeah and that's a
loving thing to do yes you know it will
be interesting to know if they consulted
anyone you know this happens in
Hollywood all the time as well you know
we're we're you and look thankfully it's
happening less but in the 90s and the
80s is the 70s or whatever you'd have
films that are supposed to be a about
black lives directed by white people and
you're watching it you know going oh my
goodness that's how you think we talk
that's how you think we know that's how
you think we are and it's so offensive
that's what this is sort of in the
hemisphere and also when you're sharing
like we're not saying don't share in
social media do so but Leila sad who
wrote me and white supremacy
she wrote genuine but rhetorical
question for the people with white
privilege sharing the entirety of my
book online each day's topic and the
related journaling questions on your IG
story your posts your IG TV if you're
gonna share the whole of my book with
your audience why would they need to buy
it you're essentially saying I want my
people to do the work but through me not
through her right so it's also they're
just conscious sharing conscious you
know protesting
just just say I don't know and I need
there's enough resources to go educate
yourself at this point and I think it's
just important to sort of end a little
bit on this isn't a red state blue state
republican democrat that's not that the
democrats fucked up in my opinion with
that and have missed the mark in a lot
of ways and I think that Democrats have
this like air of invincibility sometimes
of like we're progressives and sometimes
those people have the most arrogance in
the most blind spots because they think
they've just like have this shield of
invincibility around them absolutely
right and progress is messy in the youth
of the man in the perfect yeah it really
is and I think look we as black people
looks some some of what I felt in the
middle of them the me to movement was
that you know I went to I went to a a
woman women's event I was about I don't
know two three hundred women and I I
went and spoke and I spoke on Redemption
mm-hmm and the possibility of it and it
was a very hostile room because and as
was very vocally told to me we're not
ready we're not ready to entertain
redemption we're not ready it's not for
us to now be the ones to forgive mm-hmm
you know having been done to so and I
could I can understand it and the point
is when something like this has been an
honor there is a process there's a
process of pain the stages of grief you
know and it seems like the stage of
grief currently is anger the other that
all the other things didn't work yes you
know and I'm mistrust because the other
things haven't worked that image it
elicits mistrust because it feels
patronizing and disingenuous and it
doesn't it's not a good fit you you look
it looks weird the optics are off you
don't look comfortable it looks crazy
you're wearing this like a costume yeah
yeah it feels staged as opposed to
genuine and we've been we've been seeing
so much genuineness in this moment that
it highlights when it feels like sticks
out like a sore thumb when it's
else phony it does and we as black
people in this country you know there
there is gonna be a process of not
punishing people as they go through this
messy stage of enlightenment and
awakening and reaching helvering yeah
and messing up and and you know there's
gonna be a cold turkey yes yes yes as
well of like feet you know there is
gonna come a moment where people are
gonna feel like you know I don't like I
don't like how it feels to suddenly be
at work and actually I feel like I'm not
inhabiting the same space I used to do
why are they why is why is that studio
now making more films with black people
in them why why you know this thing I
mentioned earlier about direct if the if
this thing works there are gonna be more
opportunities for 80,000 movies on
Netflix there's enough for everyone but
you know what literally - like we said
with the directors to move that needle
5% 10% it feels like a threat it feels
like ground is being lost and an America
more than anyone I mean it's the it's
the only place in the english-speaking
Lange where that the only country in the
in in the world that speaks English that
has the phrase winningest that's like
that's like that's like not a word not a
word but winningest is an American word
no other english-speaking country uses
winningest and that in and of itself
shows you how much that is valued
there's a first place the second place
in a third place I know we all win it's
one of us wins I remember someone saying
to me because the the tutu to dial the
UK and you have to put a plus for for
yeah oh yeah I know I know yeah I
brother lives there we never speak
because of those two letters there you
go and number everyone even letters I've
every officially
we're gonna figure that out
real quick with Whitney's fading you
guys let me make this point but every
country has you know those those numbers
in in front of it and I remember a guy
saying to me you guys are plus four for
right know what America is and it is and
he said he said that to me in a way 44
is greater than one it's 43
Marvy number one number one the greatest
num it's all about no this is how we
this is what we do 44 doesn't register
number 2 doesn't register so to feel
like you are losing ground that being
number one yeah that's an uncomfortable
feeling for a country that invented the
word winningest and I think it's an
anthem out of the way we're programmed
because you know I'm learning as someone
that very much you know as a female
comic there was only one right one line
up one woman on the line up oh we got
our woman we're good one woman got a TV
show one woman do it or whatever um and
it took me a long time to realize that
someone else winning doesn't mean I lose
right it should go oh my god she got
that thing so I can get that thing too
right oh my god like you know when the
water rises all the ships rise together
it took me so long to realize it's not
her or me it's oh my god you got it I
can get it too I met I met so much
resistance from the generation above me
as a black actor when I first came to
this country and I could feel that I was
deemed a threat and it confused the
people who were my heroes and I was like
what is that and it made me determine to
not only not be like that but to create
spaces where we talk about
not being like that because if you look
at Jews for instance in Hollywood
part of the power of Jewish Hollywood is
the power in numbers when you are one
you can you can be picked off is the
truth of the matter but when you're
coming as a phalanx you know it's why I
love this new movement I actually you
know what when we did Selma people were
asking me half streaming for free master
by the way literally you just go to
Amazon and put in salma comes right up
you guys
trending free trending it's I I had seen
it before and I rewatched it I rewatched
it this last week and it was um watch it
again even if you've seen it watching it
now is truly wild yeah
and if you watch the scene where Oprah's
character tries to vote and can't guess
the judges and don't cry it's a
psychopath test just in case you're
curious no but you know what when we
when we did that when we did that film
gosh I forgotten the point I was gonna
make it was such a good one I had to
make it about me
I just it wasn't about me for so long
we're talking about when you remaining
Salma
being number one other actors that were
your heroes felt competitive towards you
and you were determined to not be like
that
yes and when you were doing Selma don't
interrupt
progress is messy you guys we we have we
have made that soy did something
[Laughter]
this boats doing the best I can and got
sunburned so I am doing my part no I
yeah just interrupted the melt I'm gonna
remember in the car on the way home late
it was definitely about something when
you were determined to not be
competitive with other black actors on
Selma maybe you were mentoring an actor
maybe you're supporting actors helping
black filmmakers but here's the point I
do want to make regardless of whether I
can remember you know the I determined
that I wasn't going to do that because
we see evidence everywhere of the fact
that I exactly as you say the ships rise
together and we just hadn't haven't been
programmed to do that and it is so
destructive to us but it is learnt
behaviour and habits yeah so um everyone
always asks me about my skin on the
podcast it's the whole thing we do or
the oils and the lubing up my face it's
a whole thing and I was in a very shiny
face
I discovered three new companies that
are black owned that do gorgeous skin
oils they're called a para Clure and
temmie TMI essentials by temmie
you have five cosmetics on one can be
black owned ask questions about where
you're spending your money I posted in
my stories a bunch of black on florists
a bunch of black owned fashion brands
skin brands makeup blur and stuff like
that you know a lot of us don't even
know that we're contributing this
financially all the time that's just a
mindless thing we do I just buy this
thing and I buy this thing like what you
spend your money on is a really big part
of how wealth is gonna be distributed
it's money you were gonna spend anyway
it's not being taken from you okay Estee
Lauder has enough money right now they
could use a one less billion dollars and
they'll still be fine
yes right absolutely and because a lot
of these brands are not paying for huge
famous
celebrities you know $8,000,000 to be on
their billboard you're paying $48 $36
instead of a hundred and $20 which which
I think makes the point that activism
comes in lots of different forms like
not everyone can march to be perfectly
frank not everyone should MA you know if
you have kovat please do they start Mac
don't do that you know but there are
lots of ways to be part of this and to
be part of the solution I think it's
also this is this is also a danger
burnout you know like yeah yeah yeah
yeah all these books and calling all
your black friends reading and watching
every movie and then and then you know
it's like working out you know yes just
just do it just do the 20 minutes per 30
minutes but sustain it yeah as opposed
to going to the gym for three hours and
then aching so much and then you go this
is too hard exactly it's not sustainable
right or that I've done my part syndrome
I paid my dues this is a daily practice
you know and not wearing you're not
burning yourself out that's such an
amazing point I didn't think of that
yeah it's it's it's absolutely crucial
and it's look it's also part of the
beauty of wanting to learn of wanting to
say sorry of wanting to do a lot but
white guilt is also a real thing and as
well as white privilege yes and you know
guilt and in and of itself is not a
useful emotion no you know because it's
it's not active actually myopic all
about this and it shuts you down it does
it paralyzes you yeah and so you know to
take take try if you get and take that
off the table and just think about what
what can I do you know this is you know
what you've just said there about it
that there's this this um saying which I
only now understand and I've heard it
before in relation to black people
anyway which is a existence is
resistance
you know just the very act of being
Allah
like I had a couple of days last week in
the week before we're getting out of bed
was tough because of what was happening
and it was an act of will you know and
even in relations healthcare huge huge
even in relation to to Selma you know at
in this moment you can feel like making
movies or creating art is trite in
relation to but you know it blesses my
heart so much and people watch that film
and feel like they have more of an
understanding of something yes and felt
it like I mean per your point before I
mean when you were standing I didn't
know it was a cake a cake Wizards Bridge
dragon whatever of you fucked they're
weird dungeons and dragons names um I
mean the look on your face I mean it was
just it's it's I mean and Davis
obviously brilliant the amount that was
you were just held on you to feel the
pain you know it's it's gonna it's a
painful watch and it should be right
right that sort of vicarious
understanding of to what we can and
here's the point I was gonna make Selma
doing summer moment on the bridge those
those moments of achievement for that
movement couldn't couldn't have been
achieved by King alone and what the the
thing that is beautiful about this
movement because the point I was gonna
make before as people would ask me when
the film first came out in 2014-2015 do
we need another dr. King do we need
someone because we had literally just
had Mike Brown that August before the
film came out in December and we had we
were doing press in New York and there
were people marching in the streets we
would sometimes have to stop because of
how loud the marching was it was the the
birth of black lives matter and I wasn't
able to give an answer if I'm if I'm
totally honest and what has manifested I
think is genius
cause in this country when a leader
rises who questions the distribution of
power which is what the civil rights
movement was we kill them we assassinate
them we murder them and sometimes it has
been government sanctioned so the fact
that this is a many-headed monster yeah
and you can't yeah why yes hit count was
not a concentration of one person is
also something that gives me hope and
the ability for activists to be in tweet
and post from the safety of their home
right follow them all right and be
anonymous if they so choose or be in a
community as opposed to being the the
poster child or the what
now I will say something that dr. King
did so effectively is he was able to
articulate the heart of the moment like
no one else yes and that is something
that you know you even have defund the
police to have someone out there who can
break that down so that you're not
thinking it's tantamount to abolish the
police would be incredibly useful but
this is where again the geniuses do the
work we now have so many more resources
to find out you all you have to do is go
to a website go to a follow someone on
Instagram to get the information these
are things that were not at people's
disposal in the 60s you know with
leaflets flyers right you know that's
that's all they had so we don't have
that excuse but that is one of the
things that I think is Jean it is a
genuine movement so again going back to
the there can only be one syndrome which
was prevalent in the civil rights
movement as well as well as and the
feminism movement as you know what is
that we achieve so much more as a group
as a phalanx as a team we know that and
so the fact that that is working in this
moment is beautiful to see because it's
indicative of the thing that is gonna
make this thing stick that we don't rely
on leader
but we rely on ourselves in groups
linking arms together unified learning
as we go it's a little bit more
unwieldly yeah yeah well messy but you
can't you can't find that head cut it
off and that means this has real
potential of surviving I'm gonna just
close reminding you Eddie Moore jr.
dot-com 21-day racial equity habit
building challenge if you are at a loss
of what to do if you're a loss at who to
follow don't know Brittney pack net
Cunningham Roxane gay just go to who
these people follow and just follow them
like figure it out yourself go to who
your black friends follow and go from
there
I'm gonna post all of this and my
stories what's your community phone
number do you even know I don't
I did we are I am colluding with all my
personalities to make his number more I
don't even know what is its you might be
ashamed no you shouldn't be ashamed I
should be ashamed that I know mine by
heart eight one eight two three nine
seven I have no idea what it is is it on
your Instagram it's not even in your
Instagram bio I know okay we gotta get
yeah we got to get that up so that you
guys can receive updates from David's
what he's working on what Cydonia oh you
know watch IIIi have I remember posting
it a long time ago I'm talking about
community and getting together it was a
community number I will be of service
and run your community yeah 30 30 30 go
there it is there it is yeah hey wait
till I die
eight one eight four oh eight four three
five nine
I am bullying him into doing more
outgoing texts he's not gonna be able to
read all of your goddamn texts he
doesn't have that kind of time and don't
send me scripts you guys know scripts we
can't read scripts guys it gets us in
legal trouble we cannot read unsolicited
scripts we just send them to our lawyer
and pray you don't sue us yeah and we
lawyer the fuck so but this is gonna be
a way that he can start up like it's you
can say like Selma's not free but you
know like there's so much news out there
there's so much blood reaching me she's
help I'm really patronizing but it's
just such an effective I have found such
an effective tool to sort of cut through
the clutter of the people who actually
want to hear you and because now
Instagram with the algorithm you have to
get a certain number of comments and
likes in the first 10 minutes for even
it to get into your feed yeah sometimes
it takes two days to get into someone's
feed sometimes they don't see it at all
if it doesn't get enough okay so the
people that actually want to follow you
and see all of your content might not
even be that explains a lot it's
catching me on that Wow okay I learned
the hard way and yeah it was I'm
crestfallen heartbroken frankly but yeah
this anyway it's an amazing tool and I
just I'm gonna blast that I'm gonna
start texting you guys black owned
businesses and all of this stuff here
sort of in sort of heats everything
we've talked about I'll send you guys
that directly as well and now I have to
stop sucking your life force hahaha this
has not been that at all it's been
amazing to have this conversation with
you at this time and you're a
transcendently lovely human being and so
you know to talk to you generally is is
is a good thing but to talk to you about
something meaningful is even better what
a treat
they I agree
thank you for your time I love you guys
I'm gonna shut up I always end these
very awkwardly okay I can feel the
awkward I really want to put the gum in
my mouth but they always when they hear
me chew gums or like you know ASMR they
don't like it when people like into
microphones and stuff really listen to
it and people like it or they doing what
they love it but for some people it's
very uncomfortable like nails on a
chalkboard so I don't really complain
about stalkers when you are doing this
[Laughter]
you come for you solved it so now we
know very full circle I love you thank
you movie - thank you
[Music]
[Applause]